non la parole est au président gilles
carez merci monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question concerne
également le ministre des transports le
projet du grand paris express c'est à
dire l'amélioration qui est si
nécessaire des transports collectifs en
île de france a été lancé en 2010 par
nicolas sarkozy et ce projet a été non
seulement confirmé mais aussi complété
par le gouvernement héros en prenant
mieux en compte la nécessité d'une part
de construire des lignes nouvelles de
banlieue à banlieue
mais aussi l'urgence de moderniser les
lignes existantes de rer
et grâce à cette continuité de l'action
de l'état et de la région d'île de
france et je veux saluer cette
continuité
les travaux de ce gigantesque chantier
30 milliards d'euros
démare les premiers tunnelier vont
commencer à creuser la ligne 15 au sud
de paris dès la fin de cette année et la
société du grand paris maître d ouvrage
lance des appels d'offres qui permettent
la création de plusieurs milliers
d'emplois mais surtout mais surtout des
millions de banlieusards commence à
reprendre espoir tant nos conditions de
transport en particulier domicile
travail se sont dégradées par exemple
sur la ligne à un million de voyageurs
chaque jour
elle est tellement chargé que le moindre
incident se transforme en cauchemar pour
l'usager aussi monsieur le ministre je
souhaiterais que vous nous rassure y ait
sur le déroulement de ce magnifique
chantier d'une part les délais vont ils
être tenu je pense à l'horizon 2022 pour
la mise en service de la ligne case 2022
pour le prolongement de ses hommes à la
défense qui doit doubler la ligne a est
le prolongement de la ligne 14 à mairie
de saint-ouen et puis deuxième aspect
est ce que les financements sont bien en
place et est ce que monsieur le ministre
les budgets sont tenus merci merci la
parole est à monsieur alain vidalies
secrétaire d'état chargé des transports
de la mer et de la pêche
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission de finances
je vous remercie pour votre question est
d'avoir mis l'accent d'une part sur la
continuité puisque ce projet a été
initié sous une autre majorité et qu'il
n'a pas été poursuivie avec
l'investissement de beaucoup d'élus sur
tous les bancs et deuxièmement je
rejoins vos propos sur une question qui
rejoint d'ailleurs la question de marie
george buffet je suis de ceux qui
pensent que la mobilité est d'abord une
question sociale et que dans cette
interrogation que nous avons aujourd'hui
sur l'avenir de nos banlieues d'un
certain nombre de quartiers
ce projet là est probable pour l'avenir
l'un des projets les plus porteurs d'une
réponse positive et finalement que nous
soyons tous d'accord pour le mettre en
oeuvre me paraît une bonne nouvelle pour
la démocratie au moment où certains
essayent de la dénigrer
j'ajoute que aujourd'hui nous faut de la
vigilance comme président de la
commission des finances vous en avez
parce que c'est un projet énorme 38
milliards 200 km de voies 68 stations et
à ce jour les délais sont respectés
vous le savez déclaration d'utilité
publique en été prise
les financements ont été mis en place et
notamment ce financement spécifique avec
des recettes particulier je pense qu'à
l'avenir il nous faudra garder cette
vigilance je compte sur vous je pense
tout le monde parce que nous avons tous
intérêt à la réussite de ce grand projet
qui je crois a fait honneur à la
politique monsieur le président je veux
terminer vous me permettrez part adressé
un salut républicain dans l'ensemble des
députés puisque j'ai aussi décidé après
25 ans de ne pas me représenter
ce fut équilibrée dix ans dans
l'opposition dix ans dans la majorité
cinq ans au gouvernement dans tous les
cas je suis fier d'avoir servi la france
et république
merci
merci monsieur vie d'alice
[Applaudissements]